okay so in this video we're gonna
discuss the process known as mitosis now
what I would challenge you to do is at
the end come back to the beginning of
this video right here and just watch
this this summary right here here we
have a cell and it's going to go through
mitosis and so first thing that's gonna
happen is the chromatin is gonna be
copied and so there it happened next
thing that's gonna happen is the nucleus
is gonna dissolve and there goes the
nucleus next thing would be the
chromatin is gonna condense into
chromosomes and so the strands of
chromatin condense into the X shaped
chromosomes next thing would be the
chromosomes that'll be pulled to the
equator of the cell the equator just
means the middle so they're they've been
pulled by something called spindle
fibers the next thing that's gonna
happen is the sister chromatids are
gonna be pulled apart and there they go
spindle fibers pull apart the sister
chromatids as we get near the end
cytokinesis is gonna split the cytoplasm
of the cell and there it goes and
ultimately the chromatin is gonna uncoil
back the chromatids excuse me the
chromatids are gonna uncoil back into
chromatin and lastly perhaps the nucleus
is gonna reform and so that's a real
quick summary I know this is the video
just started and I'm already doing a
summary but if you come back to this at
the end be a nice little summary for you
so let's go ahead and get started and go
through that process that we just
discussed
so we first all first off let's ask
ourselves what is mitosis mitosis is a
type of cell division it's how your
somatic cells it's how your body cells
it's how your non sex cells divide and
so in the picture here you have a
karyotype if you recall and a karyotype
show this karyotype you can see two
chromosome ones and two chromosome 12s
and two chromosome tens this is a
karyotype of a somatic cell if you
recall somatic cells are also a diploid
diploid simply means you're gonna have
two of every chromosome that's why you
see two chromosome 15s and
- chromosome 20s because diploid cells
have to of every chromosome so when you
think of somatic cells that are diploid
cells of the body that go through
mitosis well we know there's somatic and
diploid but examples would be like
muscle cells and skin cells and liver
cells and so when we shift our focus
away from the human human body and we
talk about mitosis and other forms of
life you know it's really how other
forms of life can even a sexually
reproduce bacteria do a process called
binary fission which is fairly similar
to mitosis it's not exactly and so
organisms like you see here in the
picture these organisms will actually
split themselves into two it's a very
rudimentary form of reproduction it's
called asexual reproduction it doesn't
require a second individual and so the
end result are gonna be two genetically
identical daughter cells here's that
same animation again the chromatin just
copied itself the nucleus dissolved the
chromosomes are forming the chromosomes
being pulled to the middle of the cell
the chromatids are being pulled apart
cytokinesis divides the cell the
chromatin uncoils and a nucleus reforms
but when we examine these the two nuclei
we can see the inside of the nuclei the
DNA is identical to red strands of DNA
to black strands of DNA and to green
strands of DNA so mitosis makes exact
copies okay so I want to address the
larger picture here mitosis is just a
very small step in the life of a cell
the overall life of a cell is what we
call the cell cycle you can see in the
picture of mitosis is just a small
portion of the overall what's called
cell cycle so by definition the cell
cycle is simply the repeating set of
events in the life of a cell and we can
break down the cell cycle into various
stages and that's kind of what the rest
of this video
is going to address we're gonna address
in a moment a stage called interphase
interphase even has a few sub stages the
g1 the s and the g2 stage after
interface comes prophase and then comes
metaphase and then comes anaphase and
then comes telophase the last four
prophase metaphase anaphase telophase
these are the stages known as mitosis so
when we when we look at the picture we
can see that mitosis again is only four
stages and it's a fairly small step or I
should say a fairly small portion of the
life of a cell so let's go ahead and
talk about interphase first after all
interphase from the picture you can see
is the vast majority of the life of a
cell so let's first address interphase
after all it is the largest portion of
the cell cycle and so interphase can be
divided into three sub stages and you
saw their abbreviations a moment ago the
first is called the g1 stage the G you
may hear it stands for growth because
the cell does grow you might also hear
that the G stands for gap the gap of one
stage because this is the first gap
prior to prior to mitosis and so during
the g1 stage the cell performs its
normal functions and so this is where a
cell of your stomach for instance would
be releasing digestive enzymes to help
break down your food because that's what
cells of the stomach normally do this is
where your cells of your nervous system
would be like I wouldn't make brain
cells would be sending messages all
around all around your nervous system
because that's what they normally do so
during the g1 stage cells are performing
their normal jobs eventually the cells
will grow and they will also create more
organelles more mitochondria more
vacuoles more lysosomes more rough and
smooth ers so next comes the S stage and
the S stands for the word synthesis
which simply is a word that means to
make so something is made during the S
stage and that something happens to be
DNA in the picture here this is going to
be an animation we have six pieces of
what are called chromatin in the cell to
red to black to green so these are these
are gonna represent the strands of DNA
that are in the cell known as chromatin
watch the animation right now you can
see the chromatin was duplicated that's
characteristic of the s stage of
interphase and then we have the final
stage of interphase called the g2 stage
and the G might you may hear it stands
for growth or gap - it's the second gap
prior to mitosis and so this is the g2
stage and like it says the the cell will
grow some more but ultimately the cell
is going to be performing its normal
function and so all of these events are
getting the cell ready for mitosis so
interphase is not actually part of
mitosis let's go into mitosis next so
mitosis begins with this step called
prophase so prophase is the first
mitosis stage and what happens one of
these what are one of the notable
features that happens is the the stringy
version of DNA again that's called
chromatin is gonna coil into these X
shaped chromosomes watch the animation
in the animation you can see the stringy
threads of DNA disappear and the X
shaped chromosomes up here next the
nucleus is going to dissolve and there
it goes and when that happens the the
chromosomes are simply spilled into the
cytoplasm of the cell
finally some what's gonna happen is
objects called spindle fibers are gonna
form you might know that cells contain
an organelle called centrioles and from
the centrioles these spindle fibers are
going to grow I will show you what their
job is in just a moment but the spindle
fiber fibers begin to grow and form
during the prophase stage let's move on
to the next stage called metaphase so
when we move on to the next stage called
metaphase metaphase is the second stage
of mitosis
there's really one big characteristic
event that happens during metaphase the
spindle fibers are gonna attach to the
centromeres of each chromosome so there
they go the spindle fibers just attached
to the central location of the
chromosomes well that's not the main
characteristic right there the main
characteristic of metaphase is this
right here the spindle fibers are gonna
pull the chromosomes to the cell's
equator watching my animation those X
shaped objects are being pulled to the
cell's equator the equator is again just
the central line like an imaginary
central line like the earth has as a the
equator the so does the cell and so
that's a very straight forward
characteristic image of what cells look
like when they're in metaphase all the
chromosomes are going to be lined up
along the middle like that well now
we're gonna set up what's called
anaphase so now we move on into anaphase
anaphase is the third stage of mitosis
and what you see right here in the notes
the this really is the characteristic
step of the characteristic feature of
anaphase spindle fibers are gonna rip
apart the chromosomes remember that one
chromosome is made from two chromatids
the two halves of a chromosome are
called sister chromatids so watchin the
animation the sister chromatids get
pulled apart one of the chromatids get
pulled to the left one of the chromatids
got pulled to the right and so you have
this collection of chromatids on the
left of the cell another collection of
chromatids and the right of the cell and
so when we get near the end we come to
the stage called telophase telophase is
the fourth and final stage of mitosis
and so what happens is those spindle
fibers their job has been fulfilled they
really have no purpose any longer so
they're gonna simply dissolve there they
go in the animation another
characteristic of telophase is that a
process called cytokinesis may occur now
cytokinesis doesn't always occur during
telophase it might even begin during
I'm just putting it in these notes right
here during telophase because we're
winding down we're getting near the end
but watch the animation right down the
middle of that cell site if aneesa's is
gonna occur splitting the cytoplasm of
the cell on the left from the cell on
the right that's called cytokinesis the
next thing that's gonna happen again the
nucleus is going to reform you know that
these are all eukaryotic cells so they
all have to possess a nucleus so there
goes the nucleus it's reforming
protecting this the the pieces of DNA
that it's surrounded and lastly one of
the final things is that the chromatids
those sister chromatids are gonna unwind
back into their linear strands of DNA
called chromatin so here we have in the
animation the linear strands of
chromatin called the linear strands of
chromatin reform the chromatids unwind
back into the chromatin and so the end
result is where are two identical
diploid cells and notice how they're
identical because they each have the
same amount and the same type of DNA in
them two red pieces of DNA for each two
black pieces of DNA and two green pieces
of DNA and so I kind of brushed over
cytokinesis really quick I want to just
mention a few other features about
cytokinesis sometimes it starts during
anaphase sometimes it starts during
telophase but ultimately cytokinesis is
the dividing of the cytoplasm it's just
a little different in animal cells
versus plant cells so in the picture we
have an animal cell in animal cells
during cytokinesis the sound membrane is
simply going to be is gonna pinch inward
until eventually those two cells break
apart from one another well that's great
in animal cells but the problem with
plant cells plant cells have that hard
outer layer called the cell wall to them
and so plant cells are a lot more rigid
they're not able to just pinch so in
plant cells here we have an animation in
plan
cells you can see a plate begins to form
down the middle and it grows outward
eventually separating the two new cells
now this doesn't happen over and over
and over and over like you see in my
animation I'm just allowing it to happen
more than once just to draw your
attention to it and so ultimately that
cell plate is going to form and there
you go the cells are gonna split apart
and so there's a little bit of a
distinction between cytokinesis of
animals and cytokinesis of plants so as
we wrap up this video here's a little
practice quiz here I'm gonna go through
a series of photographs pause the video
try to figure out what stage of the
cycle is this is this a picture of
interphase prophase metaphase anaphase
telophase pause the video I'm going to
go over the answers in three two one
so the hint in case you're stuck the
hint is right there you can see the red
chromatids are being pulled apart a half
of the chromatids are being pulled to
the right of the cell the other half of
the chromatids are being pulled to the
left of the cell that's a characteristic
of anaphase here's another one so same
thing pause the video is this and think
about it is this interphase prophase
metaphase anaphase telophase I'm going
to show the answer in three two one
so first of all a clue right there I've
highlighted the clue that you can see
that the red X shaped chromosomes are
aligned in the middle of the cell
this is a picture that is characteristic
of metaphase here's another one is this
a picture of interphase prophase
metaphase anaphase and telophase pause
the video I'm going to show the answer
in three two one
so there's a couple clues I can give you
clue number one you can see the blue
spindle fibers are forming clue number
two you can see that the nucleus is
starting to break apart
you see there's holes in the in the
nucleus you can see the nucleus is
dissolving clue number three you can see
the X shaped chromosomes are
to form so there's three clues right
there that this is a picture
characteristic of prophase here's
another one is this a picture of
interphase prophase metaphase anaphase
telophase pause the video I'm going to
go over the answer in three two one
so I think the feature that gives this
answer away is you can see that there
are not one but there are two nuclei
appearing in this picture and this
happens during telophase telophase is
near the end there's gonna be two nuclei
and eventually that cell will split
right down the middle here's the last
picture again is this interphase
prophase metaphase anaphase telophase
pause the video I'm going to go over the
answer in three two one
so what we have here is a nucleus that's
intact this is a normal-looking cell
right here this is a normal-looking cell
because the cell is probably doing its
normal function this is something that
is very characteristic of interphase and
so there you go if you're in my biology
class I would try to try to answer these
questions right here on a separate sheet
of paper and I'd be happy to check your
answers before class or after class good
luck